hello yeah sister listen tell mom I knew
as well please prepare my food here okay
I'm hungry I'm gonna come home make sure
it's ready everything that I like how
many of us do this in Ramadan Habib
beloved we should not treat our beloved
ones like this especially our mothers
and our sisters then our maids to come
home and demand things what they're
doing they're doing it for the sake of
Allah make easy on them
the Prophet peace be upon him how was he
with his wives when they would go home
he would help them if he had the free
time and we should do the same with our
wives and our sisters and our mums we
should not treat them that back there
our slaves so when you go home next time
ask your mom and sister do you need help
is there anything that I can do instead
of demanding things that's it or amadai
reminder for me I'll see that they hope
you guys enjoyed that video don't forget
to share subscribe and like and join the
dowel movement while becoming at our
movement member today by clicking the
link below